thank Samir let's drill down into
different types of ideas that you could
dream up the first type of idea is a
simplify idea with these types of ideas
you're trying to make a process or a
task much easier for your user Instagram
did this by simplifying the process for
combining images they have an app called
layout which allows you to combine
photos from your camera phone and to
customize layouts
another type of an idea is a me-too idea
it's where you take a current idea and
you bring it to a new market
Flipkart is a me-too idea similar to
Amazon the company leveraged market
insights in India to pioneer concepts
such as cash on delivery
Flipkart also partnered with other
companies to provide exclusive sales on
its website since it had such a deep
understanding of India and its users
needs virtual eyes is another type of
idea it involves moving an activity to
the online space need to do your taxes
TurboTax allows you to send off your tax
forms electronically you can even do
them from your mobile phone or tablet
need to hail a cab lyft makes this
process also really seamless you can do
it right from your mobile phone for this
type of idea it's important to think
about how you can leverage existing
technologies or build upon new
technologies for example lyft use the
fact that everyone has cell phones and
GPS locations to provide cab service to
people on demand you might also try to
remix or combine two or more ideas SLAC
an online messaging tool is one great
example of a remix idea slack is a team
communication tool that streamlines
email chat and private group messaging
while making all content searchable I
can chat up my fellow course developers
or I can put in an order for some
late-night food finally there are types
of ideas that seem impossible or almost
impossible these types of ideas are just
like Google's Project loon Project loon
attempts to bring Internet to the rural
and remote areas of the world using
helium balloons and the next few
exercises you'll look at some different
companies and determine which types of
ideas apply to them